[Music]
[Applause]
peaceable assembly
is the cornerstone to the ongoing fight
for equal rights
and in america we look towards the civil
rights movement of the 1950s and 60s as
our primary model
it all started when mrs rosa parks
wouldn't give up her seat on the bus to
a white man
this is rehearsal men getting to know
their machines
but at the dawn of world war ii over 20
years before the famous march on
washington
a hundred thousand black activists came
within 10 days
of marching on the capitol forcing a
crucial early inflection point
in the fight for civil rights the march
on washington of 1941 was a precursor to
the more famous march in 1963
and although the one in 1941 did not
actually happen
it was successful in achieving its
objective
so how do you quickly mobilize a hundred
thousand americans in a time long before
social media or even television this is
the story of the march that almost
happened
and the man behind it
[Music]
though the civil rights act of 1875
technically guaranteed equal rights
lacks enforcement various supreme court
rulings
intimidation segregation and violence
systematically ensured that people of
color remained
left out of the american dream
it would take almost another century to
put an end to segregation
and begin the long process of equal
rights
but icons who led the civil rights
movement like rosa parks and martin
luther king
didn't exist in a vacuum there are a lot
of players who didn't wind up becoming
household names
[Music]
although the civil rights movement that
we're most familiar with begins in
1955 with the montgomery bus boycott it
had
roots in a much earlier period in many
ways the
strategies and the tactics and some of
the people involved
were the same enter a philip randolph
they want
complete equality social economic and
political
and no force under the sun can
stem and block and stop
this civil rights revolution although
randolph is
probably less well known to most people
today
he was in the time one of the most
prominent
and respected leaders in the black
movement
roy wilkins with a philip randolph they
have fought their fight
all of their adult lives born in 1889
randolph was raised in florida migrating
up to new york city as a young adult to
study economics and philosophy
he was drawn to the to socialism into
the socialist party
he started a newspaper called the
messenger it was very much
working-class oriented publication the
messenger advocated for black unions
resisted the draft in world war one and
pushed for integration inequality
across the board as a major promoter of
black artists the messenger is also
credited for helping launch an explosion
of music
art and literature that began in the
1920s known today
as the harlem renaissance
[Music]
randolph's high profile from the
messenger plus his reputation as a union
organizer
caught the attention of 500 overworked
underpaid
railroad workers in 1925
a secret meeting in harlem established
the first all-black union
the brotherhood of the sleeping car
porters
the brotherhood of sleeping car porters
is a union
of railway porters but its routes
go back to the end of the civil war a
man named george pullman
organized a company to provide sleeper
cars
for railway travel it's sort of similar
to
first class travel today on airlines
except in this case of course
he drew on a black labor force
exclusively who would
serve people food clean up after them
make their bed
they weren't even accorded the dignity
of having their own names
they're all called george
despite the demeaning nature of the work
this job offered one of the only
upwardly mobile opportunities for black
americans who migrated to the north
hoping to escape the jim crow south
it was a an occupation of some
respectability i mean it was after all
in this period
when most black laborers were on
plantations and farms and so they were
looked up to
[Music]
while white travelers let these porters
shine their shoes
make their beds and serve them food the
brotherhood quietly and methodically
organized using the motto fight or be
slaves
randolph led an expansion of the union
to over eighteen
thousand members nationwide and
ironically a key to the brotherhood's
success
was the very system that relegated them
to their servile cast
the railroad the very nature of the work
enabled them to develop strong
connections among themselves
a pride and a militancy that one them
considerable
approval in the black community as a
whole porter gets on a train in new york
and he travels to atlanta and maybe down
to florida
or louisiana up to chicago or to
california
and in the process they're making
connections among communities that
otherwise might be isolated
black newspapers like the chicago
defender would use
porters to distribute their papers they
become the instruments of communication
nationwide people would get information
about what was going on in chicago
in mississippi and vice versa and the
porters were instrumental in
creating that sense of community and of
connection
this was their social network the
powerful potential of which
randolph cultivated to push for better
working conditions
and higher pay but up to this point
randolph had not yet been able to
leverage this power
beyond union organizing and collective
bargaining but that would all change
after pearl harbor
december 7th 1941
a date which will live in
infamy
as fdr's war mobilization began to lift
the nation out of the great depression
african americans were left out of the
boom black americans were
excluded by large from fairly lucrative
jobs in many cases in these defense
industries
and randolph as a union leader
raised a protest to the government that
if they did not deal with this problem
that is the racial discrimination
against black workers
that he would bring a march on
washington
and as it turns out randolph had a
supporter in the white house
the first lady who took a greater
interest in civil rights issues than her
husband
in his 1941 correspondence with eleanor
roosevelt
randolph put the white house on notice
of his plans to organize a march on
washington
to advocate for the right to work but
president roosevelt's priority was to
mobilize the war effort as quickly and
smoothly as possible
he rejected randolph's demands outright
undeterred
randolph continued to plan the march and
words spread through the brotherhood's
massive network
with less than two weeks before the
march the first lady helped arrange a
meeting between randolph and president
roosevelt
in the oval office it was not just him
it was also walter white
who was the head of the naacp
and mary mcleod bethune who was a major
leader
among black women's organizations and
roosevelt
seemed to want to avoid actually
addressing
the demands that randolph had made
randolph at some point
interrupts him and says you know if we
don't get
some satisfaction on our demands we will
bring a hundred thousand black
protesters to washington dc
and roosevelt had snapped back and he
was incredulous
he turned to walter white and asked him
well can he do that
which white answers yep he could do that
and the reason he could do it was
because of
the sleeping car porters
president roosevelt grudgingly signed in
executive order 8802
ensuring fair hiring practices to black
americans and establishing the fair
employment practices commission which
was empowered to investigate and
overturn
race discrimination in industries
engaged in military production
this was a major early victory for the
civil rights movement
made possible by a philip randolph's
ability to quickly mobilize black
americans
in a time when the closest thing we had
to mass communication
was fdr's fireside chats nobody knows
when total victory would come but
randolph did have to make some
concessions
whose original demands included the
desegregation of the armed forces
for roosevelt that was a bridge too far
who feared alienating military brass
just before the war
and going head-to-head with southern
democrats in congress
[Music]
randolph continued his fight after the
war organizing protests outside of the
democratic national convention in 1948
and shortly after truman won the
election he signed executive order 9981
desegregating the armed forces we look
at the martin washington 41
that didn't happen the movement
continued
you know that you don't win it in a
single battle it is a long
drawn-out struggle
two decades later a philip randolph
would finally get his march on
washington
playing the lead role in organizing the
largest civil rights demonstration
in american history today the city of
washington takes notice
our leaders a philip randolph roy
wilkins
reverend king received the keys to the
city then the following year
this happened i am about to sign into
law
the civil rights act of 1964. it's
fair to say that without the march that
would have been very unlikely that there
had been very much progress passing that
legislation
a philip randolph's fingerprint on the
civil rights movement remains indelible
his persistence strategies and tactics
are timeless
and are studied by anyone hoping to
organize for change
[Applause]
today
you